[Music]  Wendy Williams is taking a break the TV  host announced the news on Wednesday's  episode of the Wendy Williams Show  revealing that she's taking three weeks  off due to issues with Braves disease a  cause of hyperthyroidism my doctor has  prescribed are you ready  as of today three weeks of vacation the  53 year olds health update comes one  week after she took three days off from  her syndicated talk show to battle  flu-like symptoms on Valentine's Day she  shared this Instagram video sipping  orange juice and relaxing at home a few  days Williams returned to her show on  Monday and told viewers she was feeling  much better I must say it's good to be  back I apologize to those of you who had  tickets for the shows Wednesday Thursday  and Friday I was not here  I was fluish with complications but no  more  you